Muslim travel ban the Supreme Court has
sort of reinstated part of Donald
Trump's latest Muslim majority country
travel ban this is a very interesting
legal situation trumpets are freaking
out as if this is some kind of amazing
victory for the travel ban you've got to
be really clear here this does not mean
much about whether the travel ban will
ultimately be upheld or struck down when
the Supreme Court hears it in October
okay what the Supreme Court has ruled is
while we review the broader case which
will be heard in October we are going to
lift some of the preliminary injunctions
and court orders which stopped
implementation of the travel ban right
this is not a decision about the
legality or constitutionality of the
travel ban the court said Monday that
Trump's ban on visitors from Iran Libya
Somalia Sudan Syria and Yemen can be
enforced if the visitors lack a quote
credible claim of a bona fide
relationship with a person or entity in
the u.s. so what that means is that for
now non nationals from the six listed
countries that have no bona fide
relationship with a person or entity in
the u.s. meaning you know they're
tourists they're not coming to the u.s.
to study or for business they can be
blocked from entering the United States
okay very interesting on a few levels
number one what we had here was a
preliminary injunction in other words
this is an injunction that is granted
before the ultimate legality or
constitutionality of a law is determined
usually you will grant a preliminary
injunction if there could be irreparable
harm done by the law there's no doubt
whatsoever that there will be harm from
not being able to come to the United
States for some people but the question
is will it be irreparable I would argue
yes if you're seeking refugee status and
until October you are banned from coming
to the US because of this travel ban you
can get killed in the meantime because
you're not granted refugee status
I believe that death is irreparable harm
yeah it's also interesting how this band
has gotten so incredibly narrow over
time at first it was Trump saying that
he was going to ban all the Muslims
temporarily until we can find out what's
going on - then it was a list of seven
countries for 90 days in a list of six
countries and now with the courts new
ruling you have to have some sort of
bona fide connection to family or school
or work here so and that's also
temporary so I mean this is really going
to be ineffectual more so than just
unamerican or Islamophobic not only that
you mentioned a 90 day and the temporary
thing by the time the Supreme Court
hears the full arguments in the fall
that 90-day period to figure out what
the hell is going on as Donald Trump
said is going to be over right the
Supreme Court could according to some
legal experts in October say you know
what this was temporary and it's over
thus there is really nothing for us to
decide at this point it's not really
about the travel ban anymore it's about
does the president that the office of
the president have the authority to
issue this type of travel ban Trump will
call it a victory Trump fists are
already saying it's a victory our voice
mail today relates to this but legal
experts are saying that what the Supreme
Court has approved here is so limited
it's merely the removal of a preliminary
injunction on some parts of version 2 of
the travel ban which was already much
narrower than version 1 it's not really
any kind of legal victory and that's why
I think it's going to be so hard to
enforce if you remember Trump's first
first travel ban that just took effect
right away yeah just out of the blue
people didn't really know how to respond
to it
yep now you're going to have lawyers
dealing with customs the ACLU is going
to get involved and this is supposed to
take place starting on Thursday within
72 hours of yesterday's decision
basically and for me the more pertinent
question is does this keep us safer I
mean sort of the key aspect of this
entire thing right does something like
this keep us safer in the United States
we've already talked about how the
countries listed have historically not
exported terror to the United States to
begin with that's the real question that
we're going to be digging into between
now and the eventual Supreme Court
hearing in October